hi there steve kaufman here day 72 of my
90 day challenge in korean
uh what's that leave me 28 days i better
get a move on
i
phoned up the korean newspaper where i
had my interviews three four weeks ago
and where i was so excited that i had
been able to carry on this whole
interview
in korean
and i
was checking on whether they had
published the article which they had and
i received a copy of it
and i was trying to speak in korean and
i totally failed
and i kind of have the feeling that my
korean has been slipping
and i think it dates from when i went to
san diego and then of course the whole
ukraine situation which has got me very
interested in the events there i mean i
literally for the last few weeks i've
listened to more
russian and now recently ukrainian
than
korean
and one thing that is true is i have
found like when i did chinese and you
know i basically
from
standing still to
completing my uh british foreign service
exam was like nine ten months
concentration i mean there i was doing
six seven hours a day and i was only
doing one language
it's it's the fact that i'm now maybe
doing two hours a day of korean and
maybe
listening to the other two or hours or
so or watching
uh yeah ukraine in a russian it's it's a
diversion and and that hurts you i find
some people can do it some people can do
two three languages at the same time
i can't and when i had that conversation
then i was more immersed focused on
korean which i am not now
however
uh so what i'm gonna do here the other
thing is as i'm reading these
fighting my way through these uh
podcasts on literature
this is kim jong-un's
podcast and reading them
i mean it's very difficult stuff
i can more or less make it out
when i read it uh
some of the words that i have looked up
i may forget them again and i'll click
on the yellow word but by and large i
can pick my way through it
i don't understand it when he speaks
like i i get the odd word but i don't
really follow the drift that well
um some of it is pretty esoteric i don't
know that i'd understand it in english
um
really history and current events is
more my bag what i'm interested in
however the um kim young is kind of an
enchanting type of guy because of his
voice and then he kind of meanders
around subjects and i feel that it's
it's stretching my
knowledge because i'm listening to a
korean intellectual
uh talk about life and art and
literature and
and
things that concern him and so that's
kind of
expands me a little bit whereas focusing
every day on politics and current events
i'm learning more facts and gaining some
perspective on events but it's not
expanding my mind so i'm hanging in with
this cameo but i made for the last 28
days and if i should add two that just
as with when i did czech and i had these
uh toki cesco min lost which were quite
difficult
but were giving me a glimpse into the
austro-hungarian empire even older
history historical events in in
czechoslovakia
it was very difficult but i had a whole
year to kind of meander through it so i
wasn't worried that i wasn't
consolidating
but i kind of feel now i have to try to
consolidate so i don't have a year to
spend
or six months to spend with kim ying ha
if i'm going to try to demonstrate some
improvement in my korean so i'm
consolidating i've already started going
through those patterns that i had
on our exchange link i had translated
and recorded in korean i'm going to go
through some of my easier content i'm
going to re-read and re-read those
uh i think i've done eight or nine of
kim jong-un's podcast going to read read
them again some of the lessons that i've
already done
i think i'm going to try here in these
last 28 days to to consolidate again
uh
again it's something that i wouldn't do
if i had if i was just off on my usual
meander with no particular timelines as
was the case with russian in czech or
portuguese for that matter
um so i'm going to try to consolidate
see if it makes me perform a little
better in the sort of talking
scenarios um just to a quick note on the
uh ukraine
uh i've discovered some very interesting
sources on the internet there's this
savic shuster which is a tv show which
is on the internet
shuster live and it's half in ukrainian
so when i are more so when i listen i
understand the russian i don't
understand the ukrainian that well
although i understand ukrainian better
than korean partly because i'm familiar
with the context partly because a lot of
words are similar to russian and so what
i now do to get better my ability to
understand koreanism
ukrainian is improving so what i do is i
take
articles
from online ukrainian newspapers i put
them into google translate
and i have russian so i go from
ukrainian to russian so i see how the
ukrainian words change into russian
words it's a lot of h's in
in ukrainian and you know many is i
can't remember what it was but it's
bahata or something and pama hot and
lots of hots going on and hoes so i got
to try to get used to they kind of throw
me off but if i get used to those uh
that's going to help me
uh and if i'm confused if even the
russian is unclear i just can't
switch it to english so easily so google
translate is actually a tremendous tool
for language learning especially if
you're trying to get the gist of very
similar languages
um
yeah i might just finish with because i
i had a a video somewhere ago where i
spoke about the situation in ukraine and
i said that i thought that putin
was
saber-rattling
and creating this kerfuffle in the
crimean uh as a means of putting
pressure on the situation in ukraine
which had kind of
gotten out of control while he was off
watching the olympics
uh i don't think that was the case
uh
things have moved so quickly in russia i
have to assume that he had planned this
ahead of time
uh he did say on march the fourth that
he wasn't going to
annex the crimean and then he did so
whether that was being duplicitous or
whether events just got out of control i
don't know and this gets back to
tolstoy's comment in the war and peace
about how there's a decision here in the
position they're in a decision here and
pretty soon the thing gets momentum and
you've got this war where people are
dying
i can't imagine that putin will walk
into
eastern and southern ukraine i think
there's a fair amount of alarm out there
justifiably so
uh nothing would stop him i mean there's
no
there's you know the his army like
russia would be strong enough to go
wherever they wanted to go but the
long-term consequences for russia for
ukraine
uh for the world economy i mean the
damage to russia's economy ukraine's
economy the economy of all the countries
around there
latvia for example even with the
sanctions they're very much affected
europe
um i just can't imagine
and so
being the eternal optimist
my optimistic scenario is that in
ukraine they will come up with a
government that
is
acceptable to people both in the
west and central parts of the country as
well as in the eastern and southern
parts of the country
that ukraine will have a stronger sense
of its identity than it had before
because they have a
for at least a period a sense of a
common
uh enemy
uh
and that uh however they will not want
to join nato and i hope they don't
uh
that there will be an association of
some kind and greater
um
involvement with the european union
and hopefully that becomes a sort of a
bridge with even with russia that uh
tones down the degree of mistrust that
has
developed between russia and the west
over the
last decade and that it might in fact
end up being a bit of a milestone and
things start winding down
towards a situation where
the greatest communist interest of most
people prevails
time will tell
there have been
uh
very tragic
uh events in the 20th century that
unfolded in the other direction in other
words not in the direction of common
sense
okay thanks for listening and as i say
i'm going to be consolidating
my korean i was oh and i'm going to go
tomorrow night to a meeting of the
korea they have like the korean canadian
businessman's association or something
and they have a get to know each other
get together
thing so i'm going to go there they're
all mostly young
you know movers and shakers business
people so when they see an old
geezer like me come in they're not that
interested in talking to me and if i hit
them with my korean they'll be even less
interested in talking to me but
hey
why do i care that's what i'm going to
do tomorrow night bye for now